[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente
lula 2022 la campaña presidencial parece
haber comenzado en brasil luego de que
la justicia anulara todas las condenas
en contra del exmandatario luiz inácio
lula da silva el ex presidente
intercambio acusaciones con el actual
jefe de estado ya ir bolsonaro a quien
según encuestas le ganaría en las urnas
y en eeuu comenzó el juicio en contra de
direct show bing el policía que asesinó
a georges lloyd un caso de violencia
policial que derivó en una reflexión
sobre el racismo estructural tras la
cual se llevaron a cabo una serie de
cambios en la unión americana y oprah
winfrey se consolida como la reina de la
televisión su explosiva entrevista se
convirtió en una de las más pautas en la
historia de eeuu el más reciente de una
vida de logros
y vamos de inmediato a brasil para
nuestra historia principal el ex
presidente luiz inácio lula da silva
tiene el camino libre para aspirar a la
presidencia en 2022 luego de que un juez
de la corte suprema anulara las condenas
en su contra por corrupción al
considerar que el tribunal de curitiba
que lo sentenció no tenía la competencia
para hacerlo estos procesos deberán
comenzar de nuevo en una corte de
brasilia pero se prevé que tanto por la
edad del mandatario como por el tiempo
que llevaría el proceso podría
prescribir mientras tanto lula recuperó
sus derechos políticos y aunque aún no
ha confirmado que lo hará podría medirse
en las urnas con el actual presidente ya
ir bolsonaro en un duelo de impacto
entre izquierda y derecha que según las
encuestas marcaría el regreso del
progresismo al país
según la firma ipec lula cuenta con el
50% de apoyo de los ciudadanos en brasil
frente al 38% de bolsonaro a quien al
parecer la pandemia que catalogó como
una gripe le pasa factura
con la victoria de andrés araus en
ecuador que marca el regreso de rafael
correa
luís arse con evo morales en bolivia
alberto fernández de la mano de la ex
presidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner en argentina y el chavismo aún
en el poder en venezuela con nicolás
maduro la izquierda latinoamericana
revivió el sueño de volver a su época
dorada recordemos la
hugo chávez en venezuela luiz inácio
lula da silva en brasil evo morales en
bolivia rafael correa en ecuador néstor
y cristina kirchner en argentina y josé
mujica en uruguay la izquierda de
américa del sur se consolidó en los 2000
y así permaneció durante más de una
década
tras esperar su turno para llegar al
poder varios años ya sea por haber
estado en la cárcel por sus luchas
armadas de los 60 o por perder en las
urnas el nuevo milenio llegó con la
victoria en una elección tras otra hasta
llegar gobernar a la mayoría de los
países de la región la marea roja trajo
a la región una agenda de políticas para
garantizar la redistribución de las
riquezas
con chávez la pobreza extrema se redujo
del 62 al 31 entre 2003 y 2011 según el
banco mundial
lula sacó de la pobreza a 30 millones de
brasileños y escapó a la crisis
económica mundial de 2008
en el conocido como milagro económico de
evo morales el entonces ministro de
economía actual presidente luís arce
hizo que el producto interno bruto
creciera de 9 mil 500 millones de
dólares a más de 40 mil millones de
dólares y disminuyó la pobreza de 67 a
37 por ciento
los altos precios del petróleo y el
aumento de los ingresos fiscales por una
reforma tributaria permitieron a correr
a realizar decenas de mejoras en la
infraestructura vial educativa y de
salud diciendo que el presidente lo
había
durante el kirchnerismo en argentina el
país se convirtió en el primero en
términos de derechos al permitir el
matrimonio entre parejas del mismo sexo
y castigar el trabajo infantil también
anuló los indultos a los responsables de
violaciones a los derechos humanos
durante la dictadura y en materia
económica redujo la tasa de desempleo
pepe mujica le dio la vuelta al mundo
por sus políticas de austeridad pero su
legado fue un crecimiento económico del
75 por ciento sin embargo el
reconocimiento de estos logros depende
del espectador y del espectro político
en el que se encuentre y en algunos
casos han quedado empañados por
escándalos de corrupción y prácticas
antidemocráticas como cambios a la
constitución en aparentes intentos de
perpetuarse en el poder lo cierto es que
hay una escasez de líderes que los
releven por eso se especula su regreso
al poder
con la elección del jurado y al margen
de nuevas manifestaciones empezó en eeuu
el juicio contra el policía retirado de
repsol bin quien en mayo de 2020 le
practicó una maniobra de ahogamiento al
afroamericano george wright durante
nueve minutos mientras él repetía no
puedo respirar y todo era registrado en
un vídeo que se hizo viral y que desató
una ola de manifestaciones que sacudió a
eeuu desde la costa oeste a la este y
que llevó a una revisión profunda del
racismo estructural en el país que a su
vez derivó en decenas de cambios como el
retiro del mercado de la marca de harina
para pancakes aunque mayma el cambio del
nombre del equipo redskins y el derribo
de estatuas de personajes esclavistas
entre otros en san francisco la junta de
escuelas votó a favor de renombrar a 44
centros educativos debido a que sus
nombres están ligados a un pasado
racista o colonialista pero algunos de
estos son iconos de la cultura hispana
en california por eso no todos están de
acuerdo
veamos el informe de nuestra
corresponsal george washington abraham
lincoln y está la senadora contemporánea
diane feinstein
son algunos de los nombres que han
desatado la polémica en san francisco la
junta de escuelas aprobó cambiar los
nombres de 44 centros educativos por
estar presuntamente ligados a un pasado
racista jana está a punto de entrar en
la universidad y ha participado
activamente apoyando esta causa
a ver qué pasa con cada uno de esos
niños negros mestizos e indígenas que
tienen que ir a escuelas con nombres que
esencialmente les dicen que no importan
cada uno de esos niños negros mestizos e
indígenas que tuvieron que llevar los
nombres de los opresores de sus
ancestros en el pecho en forma de equipo
escolar
la escuela junípero serra es uno de los
centros en el punto de mira de la junta
escolar acusan a serra de evangelizar a
la fuerza a miles de nativos de
california
el arzobispo cordial jone máxima
autoridad católica en san francisco
teme que la decisión borre el pasado
parece que este movimiento que quiere
borrar la historia es reescribir la
historia con una alternativa la
narrativa alternativa no pero también no
tiene sentido uno tiene que entender
correctamente la historia para aprender
de la historia
y seguir las cosas buenas y corregir los
abusos los defectos sin embargo la junta
fue objeto de una lluvia de críticas
muchos padres de familia aseguran que
las prioridades del momento son otras
en las escuelas públicas de san
francisco han estado cerradas desde el
13 de marzo de 2020 casi un año lograr
que nuestros niños estén en persona en
un aula debería ser nuestra prioridad
número uno
y no el cambiarle el nombre a las
escuelas
vine mis cobos por cierto eso no será
gratis de dónde saldrá ese dinero ese
dinero podría ser utilizado para cosas
más importantes y en este momento
otras escuelas vinculadas a un presunto
pasado colonizador como sánchez o misión
también están en la lista pero por ahora
la junta puso pausa a su decisión
vamos a paraguay para revisar otras
noticias de las américas esta semana
el presidente mario abdo benítez se
enfrenta a una ola de manifestaciones en
rechazo a su gestión de la pandemia del
cob y 19 los ciudadanos lo acusan de
corrupción ante el colapso del sistema
sanitario y la escasez de vacunas a
pesar de que retiró de su cargo al
ministro de salud y de la dimisión de
otros cuatro ministros la oposición
considera que no es suficiente y busca
fuerzas para destituirlo a través de un
juicio político en el senado
el presidente de honduras juan orlando
hernández ha sido señalado de ayudar a
traficar toneladas de cocaína a eeuu
durante la declaración de apertura de la
fiscalía durante un juicio de un
supuesto narcotraficante en nuevayork
hernández negó las acusaciones en una
serie de tuits desde hace varios años el
presidente hondureño ha sido salpicado
por sus conexiones con narcotraficantes
incluyendo a su hermano quien fue
condenado en 2019
y hay conmoción en colombia' tras la
muerte de varios menores de edad en un
bombardeo por parte del ejército en
contra de supuestos disidencias de la
extinta guerrilla de las farc en el
departamento de guaviare en el sur del
país
diego molano el ministro de defensa que
lleva poco menos de un mes en el cargo
respondió que se cumplieron todos los
protocolos del derecho internacional
humanitario en la operación
y la cifra de la semana llega desde eeuu
17 millones ese es el número de personas
que vieron la entrevista que oprah
winfrey le hizo al príncipe harry y a su
esposa megan en la que dieron explosivas
declaraciones sobre el racismo en la
monarquía la estrella de la televisión
ha amasado una fortuna a lo largo de su
carrera la revista forbes regularmente
la cataloga como una de las mujeres más
poderosas revisemos la carrera de la
primera dama de los talk shows
en su entrevista con la pareja real
oprah winfrey mostró una vez más porque
es considerada la reina de la televisión
su cara a cara con harry y megan generó
un estimado de 20 millones de dólares en
ganancias solo en publicidad para así 10
casi creando una subasta para las
empresas que querían que su anuncio
fuera transmitido durante los cortes del
programa
sí vi es le habría pagado a winfrey más
de 7 millones de dólares por los
derechos de exclusividad para
transmitirla la cumbre del éxito de una
mujer de orígenes humildes decidió en la
pobreza en misisipí para convertirse en
la primera mujer negra en ser
multimillonaria su fama nacional llegó a
finales de los 80s como la presentadora
del show de oprah winfrey durante 25
años las más grandes personalidades se
sentaron en su set convirtiéndola en una
estrella y probablemente una de las
mejores entrevistadores de la televisión
estadounidense su influencia es
innegable se cree que su apoyo al ex
presidente barack obama en 2008 lo ayudó
a ganar millones de votos
en live por primera vez en mi vida me
siento llamada a levantarme y hablar por
el hombre que creo tiene una nueva
visión para eeuu
durante los años su red se ha expandido
lanzó varias empresas y creó su propia
productora además apoyó varias
organizaciones caritativas al principio
en su carrera winfrey reveló que fue
víctima de abuso sexual cuando era niña
y desde entonces ha lanzado esfuerzos
para perseguir a los abusadores incluso
ofreciendo incentivos financieros a
cambio de información que llevara a su
captura
bautizada como la reina de los talk
shows durante años su valor ha crecido
hasta 2.600 millones de dólares
consolidando la como una de las figuras
más prolíficas de eeuu y américa latina
se tomó españa con la exposición red de
creadores artistas emergentes del
continente americano llevaron sus obras
a la casa de américa en madrid que creó
la muestra como un espacio para ayudar a
los artistas a darse a conocer en el
'viejo continente' siete personas fueron
seleccionadas para mostrar su trabajo
desde grafitis pasando por fotografías y
cerámicas
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas sigan
viendo france24
[Música]